lorsqu'il arrive à montgaillard silva
gérard digues ou sly ne sait pas encore
ce qui l'attend il remporte le prix
langue créole 2020 en 2018 il avait déjà
été saluée par le jury
le fonds qui appelle m'avait l'âme et il
cause ils causent y cause les origines
ne va dire est qu associer y causant un
affaire d origine un identité une
recherche une initiation en fait ça m'a
écrit ça comme un seul s'ils veulent et
comme c'est une seule phrase du début à
la fin
créé en 2004 par le conseil de la
culture de l'éducation et de
l'environnement avec l'écrivain daniel
honoré pour cette 16e édition quelques
cinquante candidats se sont manifestés
c'est dire la qualité du travail debout
slide dans le magnet l'écrit à li na na
li jouets gones sont ils riment les
vrais il jouait bones on est toutes ces
bonnes mots les nouveaux par exemple n'a
bonne ronde l'âme rôle vague
broussailles et ou sans le mouvement ça
qui racontent aux 100 ha lik voix ali et
odialis des femmes et 10 il est plus
qu'éloquent les miens mais les jalousies
entre mix abonnés à oui reconnaît là
toujours dinars et nyon l'île de pau est
un élève et nous n'avons qu'à dordain
poésie et là encore cette année
bon on l'avait plus ou moins imagina
cosco vide mais au coût de 10 fois
passée la quantité la qualité auto
alliés dans deux contextes et le moule à
gagner et même les toits peu pour lui ai
pris un les bons coups de coeur et émana
les gagnantes et émotive de wind com -
ghost la hauteur slameurs et comédien
sera au début du mois de décembre à
trois bassins pour son spectacle rêves
carangues conquois langue créole est une
invitation permanente